maintain his own away from him dude  [Music]  gotcha son to be scared sometimes huh  it's bad it's just you know it's pretty  violent I understand that some of youth  behaviors would be upsetting but I urge  you to find a place where he feels safe  I think it would be good for him good  for all of us  oh my goodness think of that almost  birth of a nice dude  [Music]  and it's like he was broken before and  put back together who's this handsome  chap Brahms  how'd you come up with that he tells me  all sorts of things  okay I just think it's all a little bit  creepy is this your new friend Brahms  what are some of the things you talk  about the other families he's lensless  [Music]  gonna take this all away from him yes  it's just always that first something is  happening to him you your boy would find  it louia mommy I love you  [Music]  [Applause]  you